the commission to investigate the assault
on the capitol would be similar to the
one created after the
terrorist attacks of 9/11 the
bill is the result of a
bipartisan compromise and the commission
would be made up of five republicans and
five democrats from both parties
they would have investigative powers but
despite the bipartisan agreement the
leaders of the republican party
expressed their opposition to the project and
former president ramón said in a
statement that the project was a
trap even so 35 republicans in the
house of representatives voted with the
democrats in favor of it  create the commission
some republicans made it clear
that they believe the commission is
necessary to prevent
similar attacks in the future
the commission will be charged with
investigating the attack on january 6 and
providing a report to congress before the
end of the year but so that  the commission
is created the bill
would also have to be approved by  the senate and
it is still not clear if it has the support
of the 60 senators that would be
necessary
both in washington alexandra limón